[Applause]
[Music]
december 1st 2001 is a day that has been
seared into the collective memory of the
argentine people on that day the then
minister of economy domingo felipe
cavallo announced the implementation of
the freezing of bank deposits popularly
known as el corralito from that moment
on argentines could not withdraw more
than 250 pesos at that time equivalent
to 250 dollars from their bank accounts
of course the popular reaction was not
long in coming and for days the protests
grew and grew
[Music]
the iconic image that has remained in
the collective memory has been that of
groups of people gathered in front of
bank branches and headquarters banging
pots and pans and demanding the full
return of their deposits the chaos was
so great that a little more than two
weeks later on the 20th december
president fernando de la rua was forced
to resign after a day of protests in the
plaza de mayo that resulted in at least
29 deaths 20 years have passed since
then and here in visualpolitik we are
wondering a few things why exactly did
the correlator happen what were the real
reasons for the biggest economic crisis
in argentina's history and perhaps the
most important question of all is there
a chance that we will see a similar
situation again listen up
[Music]
road to the abyss
you know that here on visualpolitik we
love argentina and what do you want me
to say i think that if one thing has
become clear after a long list of videos
we have published about this country
this is the 21st one by the way it is
the clear predilection that argentina
has for having enormous government and
let's not kid ourselves in practice
there are only three ways to finance a
gigantic government a suffocating tax
burden chronic indebtedness or an
uncontrolled monetary release well
throughout history we can find
governments that have tried to spend
lavishly by resorting to one of these
sources of financing however the
peculiarity of the argentine case is
that since the 1940s practically all
governments have relentlessly used and
abused these three tools at the same
time this is what explains the eternal
gaucho crisis the mother of all
argentina's ills a constant of all
governments of any flavor unaffordable
public spending a policy that has lurked
since the 1940s and look how much it has
ringed always reaping the same results
crisis crisis and more crisis because
basically all the cards are on the table
the problem with debt is that it has to
be repaid and refinanced and when you
don't do that the financing becomes
scarce and more expensive then on the
taxation side it's the same old story as
private sector incomes fall and contract
revenue collection ends up decreasing in
the medium term and the informal economy
is also encouraged therefore the various
governments were left with no other
choice but to throw themselves into the
arms of monetary issuance to keep up
with their policies of more and more
public spending the abuse of this tool
has been such that has made skyrocketing
inflation a chronic evil of the
argentine economy an economy that went
through a process of very strong
hyperinflation between 1989 and 1990
which as economists pablo guido and
gustavo lazari argue meant the death of
money
[Music]
as we covered in a past video entitled
the time when argentina almost changed
paths the only time when it seemed that
argentina really wanted to change course
was under the government of carlos sal
menem with the help of his minister of
economy domingo cavallo launched a bold
process of reforms including the
privatization of many of the public
companies what did not disappear however
was the mother of all evils skyrocketing
public spending basically the only
difference was that instead of financing
it with inflation that is returning
again and again and again to the money
printing machine menem's government
financed their spending policies first
with the money coming from
privatizations and then with more and
more indebtedness in other words what
menem did was to put out the fire of
hyperinflation set by the presidency of
ricardo alfonsin his predecessor in
office and to set a new course for the
country but he didn't bring about all
the changes argentina needed to get off
the ground public spending continued to
grow the early days with mercury were
very limited regulation continued to be
excessive especially with regard to
labor legislation in argentina they make
it so difficult and costly to create
jobs that in the end no jobs are created
and when they are they are created in
the informal economy check out how
things were at the beginning of the new
century
[Music]
for every 100 that appears as gross
income on a worker's pay stub only 82
dollars goes into his pocket meanwhile
the employer has to pay 133 dollars for
that 100 of gross income this means that
for every 82 dollars that a private
worker actually receives the employer
has to pay 133 dollars pablo guido and
gustavo lazzari apuntes sombra la
economia argentina 2003. and be careful
because today things are still the same
or worse to make matters worse going
back to the menem era many of the
privatizations were done in such a way
as to create captive markets that
remained in the hands of friends of the
government things got better but not so
much in the background so when menem
left the government the country still
had many many problems argentines didn't
know but the correlito was already in
the making
[Music]
tick tock
december 1999 fernando de la rue becomes
the new president of argentina the
economic situation was already
complicated at that time it was urgent
to make adjustments for example to stop
the whole i mean gaping hole the gap in
the public accounts that threatened to
turn the whole economy upside down the
countdown to economic destruction was
underway and at this point i want to ask
you a question what on earth do you
think de la rua did how did he hope to
deal with the public deficit cutting
public spending
no we are talking about argentina after
all the government's proposal was
basically based on raising taxes instead
of cutting spending of the slightly more
than seven billion dollars in public
deficit adjustments included in the
government's plan for 2001 almost 6
billion dollars would come from tax
increases just over 1 billion was to
come from spending controls it was an 80
to 20 ratio of course a political
proposal is one thing in reality is
quite another after several political
crises in november 2000 dalarus finally
acknowledged that the deficit reduction
would be far from what was expected and
the following month congress approved a
budget with a deficit of 7 billion pesos
that is 70 more than the government's
initial plan the clock was still ticking
and it already seemed clear that 2001
would be very difficult and that is
exactly how it turned out
the year 2001 was a catastrophe
investment fell by 45 consumption by
almost 10 and unemployment continued to
rise the unemployment rate reached 18
and protests led by the paroness
opposition intensified de la ruera faced
eight national strikes in his two years
of government in which pickett's also
emerged that is organized groups linked
to trade unions that during their
protests cut off roads streets and
economic activity in such a context
distrust was almost total which caused
bank deposits to plummet by 20 nobody
had any confidence in the future of the
argentine economy everything that could
be saved had to be saved
to try and reverse the situation de la
rue decided to place an economist in
favor of adjusting public spending
ricardo lopez murphy at the head of the
ministry of the economy he lasted 15
days the government only had one bullet
left to throw itself into the arms of
the father of the reform of the men era
domingo felipe cavallo in order to
maintain public spending banks and
pension funds were forced to buy public
debt while a mega swap was approved to
convert short-term debt into long-term
debt at higher interest rates which is
to say kick the problem into the future
as you can see there was all kinds of
juggling in order not to put their hand
where it was needed in public spending
and what did you expect does something
different would happen this time well
evidently not
it was an impossible situation the
government no longer had valuable assets
to privatize and raise money
international financing was closed the
imf said that without spending cuts they
could not count on it and the government
resorted to monetary issuance that is
central banking people immediately ran
to the exchange their pesos for dollars
in anticipation of what might happen
making it harder to maintain the
exchange rate while reducing foreign
exchange reserves things went from bad
to worse
all that remained was to wait for the
outbreak of the crisis
the explosion
[Music]
argentines knew that the situation was
extremely serious between january and
november 2001 bank deposits fell by
another 20 billion pesos that's 20
billion dollars of this 1.5 billion was
withdrawn from the banks on friday
november 30th it was an unsustainable
pace so the government's solution was to
create a bank holiday and restrict
withdrawals from savings and checking
accounts the measure was announced on
saturday december 1st and came into
effect on monday december 3rd a
withdrawal limit of 250 pesos per week
per account was established that is if
you have 10 000 pesos in your account
you could only access 250 pesos per week
and watch out because then the maximum
number of accounts the person could have
was reduced to two note by the way the
rest of the money could be used through
debit cards or electronic transactions
but of course we have to take into
account that at the end of 2001 very few
people were doing these kinds of
transactions in argentina this was the
corralito a correlator that as approved
by the government would be in effect for
90 days of course those three months
were enough to change the history of the
country and cause irreparable economic
damage
the measure had the opposite effect that
intended by the government instead of
generating tranquility it generated
uncertainty and chaos the measure sank
consumption and many small businesses
but argentines were also beginning to
understand what it meant to lose their
savings from one day to the next because
the end of the one-to-one convertibility
with the dollar would inevitably mean a
tremendous devaluation of the argentine
peso hence the urgency to get the money
out either you took out your savings or
you lost them and since the government
wouldn't let you take them out it was
kind of a slow motion ruin
[Music]
the government at the time sought an imf
bailout but when cavallo traveled to the
united states he was met with a
categorical response no no no enough of
your excuses if you don't put the public
accounts in order and cut public
spending we the imf are not going to put
more money in no way not even as a joke
soon the situation degenerated to such a
level that desperation looting and
clashes with the police became a daily
occurrence finally on december 19th
president de la rue unable to contain
the protests and looting decreed a state
of siege the same instrument used by the
various military dictatorships in
argentina to control the population it
meant throwing gasoline on a lit fire on
december 20th clashes with the forces of
law and order left 29 dead the
government was finished minutes before 8
pm the president presented his
resignation and left the casa rosada by
helicopter
[Music]
pain and ruined
three days later the legislative
assembly elected the governor of the
province of san luis adolfo rodriguez as
president who it turned out held office
just seven days before resigning from
december 23rd to december 30th a period
he used to declare the default of the
foreign debt to the unanimous applause
of the entire congress then power fell
into the hands of eduardo camano and
finally eduardo to haldi an incumbent
who had encouraged the protests and who
took office on the 1st of january 2002.
in less than 10 days argentina had five
different heads of state those were the
darkest hours during the following
months poverty multiplied the peso
continued to devalue from one to one to
one to three deposits were not returned
those who had had dollars in the bank
were robbed and their money was
exchanged for pesos that were worth less
and less of course all this meant the
end of the peso and the argentine
financial system no one in their right
mind would ever again leave their
savings in the hands of politicians
20 years later argentina is still in the
same situation the country is more
indebted than ever has the highest tax
burden in its history and annual
inflation exceeds 50 it is what is
already known as the argentine tragedy
but having reached this point it is now
your turn this time i'm going to be
direct do you think argentina has a
solution if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to visualpolitik take care and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you